we know that our universe is expanding
Brian Schmidt said that the speed of
this expansion is accelerating John
Mather detected cosmic background
radiation the echo of the Big Bang
both of these revelations fundamentally
change our view of the universe and
posed huge questions for today's
physicists the laureates met with three
young researchers to discuss the current
state of astronomy and whether this is
indeed a golden age in that field age of
astronomy so I guess we want to know if
it is from my perspective it is because
this is a time when well I not to say
that there isn't going to be another
golden age to follow but we are now at a
place where discoveries are being made
at an extraordinary pace because there's
also a lot more astronomy and there are
a lot more astronomers so we have our
astronomers and we also have more
wonderful equipment the number of
telescopes that are in space and on the
ground ER and being built is just
fantastic my impression is the rate of
discovery is continuing to increase and
so it's not it can't always continue
forever but I think astronomers have at
least a century's worth of marvelous
ideas in if you look at the things that
were submitted to the decadal survey
didn't take us a century to do the
moment so so there's a there's an issue
there here though which is that although
we've had a period of exponential growth
clearly prom with a couple of hiccups
from when you came out of graduate
school and that is made like very golden
for us because unlike your generation
our generation there were enough
professors ships for almost every
student created because of the
exponential growth so I think astronomy
itself is gonna continue to grow but I
think our ability to increase funding my
guess has leveled off I think we have
seen the end of exponential growth and
we are going to go into an equilibrium
situation I think that we will be judged
on how we are able to resolve the
problems that have been presented to us
so I think that we have been presented
with this incredible problem of the
cosmic acceleration and alongside that
the the question of the cosmological
constant problem honestly I think that
in
you know fifty years time we're gonna be
judged on whether we were able to come
to any conclusions about the problem so
I don't disagree the progress on it
cosmic acceleration has been woefully
slow in the last 13 years not for lack
of trying
certain we're using a sledge hammer
going out trying to chop down trees in a
very large force yeah but we're looking
at the right thing I don't know so I
think that we need to be very open to
ideas but astronomy and physics is
bigger than just cosmic acceleration
it's been very good to me but it's
bigger than that we have the idea that
we're being able to the first time to
look back to when the first stars
galaxies black holes form okay there are
some big questions we still don't know
what dark matter is how should we go
about answering these questions we've
got all these people are doing studying
looking at stars galaxies looking at all
this incremental stuff should we refocus
astronomy should be told the people that
aren't doing good astronomy and what I
think the process this is why I'd
disagree that it's a golden age John
Mather was correct when he said it was
the golden age for observational
astronomy like 20 years ago I was saying
exactly the same thing they launched the
Great observatories that was 20 years
ago they say image it's not to up to us
let's say to decide if this is called a
nature or not I mean it's really
something that's you know people within
exactly future people we decide there
was an age in which one was it's not
people within this age that can actually
decide if we are the good ones or not I
mean I don't think there's any way to
kind process I said it's the golden age
for theoretical physics that touches on
questions in astronomy and astrophysics
because we haven't had any really new
innovative ideas but in observational
astronomy there - right yeah that's the
research every cosmic acceleration we've
discovered extrasolar planets
we don't even know wait
we can only see 5% of the material that
makes up our universe astronomers call
the rest of it dark matter and dark
energy but we don't really understand
what these are well my thought is well
if we don't know something that's the
Golden Age of astronomy it's a question
to work on the questions that we don't
know answers to our really hard dark
matter is actually transparent it's
invisible
astronomers can tell that it's there
because it has gravity but this is a
fundamentally hard problem the dark
energy that got the Nobel Prizes last
time is even harder to study because not
only does it not name it light it
doesn't even change what you see very
much so it's a very hard thing to work
on we may never find out what that is or
we may need a discovery from some
completely different direction like the
Hadron Collider or a theorist do you
think that we are making the right
decisions on that front
it is my honest belief that dark energy
will be figured out by a theorist not by
an observer I might be wrong though
that's why W first is interesting if I
had my druthers I would be spending more
money on theorists and people I like
that but I have this similar feeling
I've been on committees about the dark
energy and what we should do I kept
asking the Sirius well what theory are
we testing and they didn't have a theory
that we were testing that they liked
yeah
sorry fun well nothing we can do as
astronomers as measurement people is
going to change any of that we need the
next Stephen Hawking or the next
Einstein to actually come up with this
thing that makes sense we don't have so
what would you like from a theory still
I say something and I one model or some
feature which characterizes more model
and that he can actually I can measure
give me a signature give me a signature
that I as an observer can go out and
test but another way of thinking of it
is well you can't always look under the
white post for the keys you have to sort
of be alert to other things where maybe
we're just not even thinking of the
right thing to think about and so you
really can't devote all of your effort
to just one big project we better do
everything else that might relate so I
actually really appreciated that they
both emphasized that there was
room for theorists and emphasize the
importance of theorist I found that
really refreshing because well but it's
particularly I'm it's great coming from
observers that they're really
understanding and maybe in that sense we
are in a golden age of understanding
science is sometimes subject to revision
it's a good thing to go out and measure
and see what the universe does because
the one thing I have learned in life is
that one should not prejudge the
universe the universe does what it wants
and our job as scientists are to figure
it out rather than than to assume it
should be the way we want it to be I
never imagined and my wildest dreams
thirty years ago we'd be able to
simulate the formation of the first
galaxies with moving particles of dark
matter it shouldn't be surprising that
invisible matter and dark energy are
complete challenge to see and they're
gonna remain a child well until some
breakthrough happens and so it could be
50 years or hundred years before that
smart person appears and I think theory
is really important to solve those
things but on the other hand preservers
like me the question is should we be
doing these great big projects and the
answer is I say hey yeah 20% of our
efforts should go into those big
problems but we need to continue to look
for planets to look for stars and
understand how the galaxy was born
understanding how you know stars are
born all these these questions it's a
very rich subject still and so it is
still a golden age although I would say
maybe not quite as golden because golden
age is not the absolute level it's the
rate of change and so I think we're in
the exponential growth that's going to
slow down a little bit but it's still a
great area to be in it's not going to
crash I think tomorrow the thing is
there's so much pressure to publish if
you don't publish you're not going to
get a job out of your PhD if you don't
publish you're not gonna get another
post off after you you know there's no
time to actually sit there and think
about the big questions there's so much
incremental science going on how would
you say we can combat this problem and
it's not actually the best way for
science for postdocs and graduate
students to be under that kind of
publication pressure I had that actually
I was hired as a civil servant they
couldn't fire me but I also couldn't
promote me until I wrote
papers so I had to write some papers too
so in my case I started off with a bunch
of papers after my PhD and then I
started the project that eventually I
got the Nobel Prize for it and that did
slow up my publication write down and
for me I took the risk I said well this
is a big project it was a high-profile
project and it was very clear we weren't
going to have a lot of papers initially
so from 1996 and 1997 I effectively
didn't publish any papers those two year
but 1998 I published papers that got
15,000 citations so it was worthwhile I
was blown away when John kind of started
out by saying I was hired as a civil
servant and then I was presented with
this challenge if well they can't
promote me if I don't get any papers
problem they can't buy me and like like
you know not getting a promotion is your
biggest problem and I'm happy I don't
think it's actually any harder for
students today than it was ten or twenty
or thirty years ago but each student has
to go through that period of worry about
what they're going to do so when I was a
student people said no you can't do what
you want to do there's no job in that
field so it happens to me it happens to
most people you can come to me and say
I've got this problem I can be like well
we can do this this and this with the
current telescope yeah do that until
this keep going on and trying to solve
the mysteries of the universe but don't
worry too much about your exact future
go in work for the present do the best
you can because the future will sort of
take care of itself and you know I can't
guarantee you're gonna get a job as an
astronomer but I think you will have a
good happy life if you do something that
you enjoy
you